elles ont été mises en place dès le mois
de mars 2020 des mesures pour soutenir
le tissu économique face à la crise
sanitaire des dispositifs utilisés dans
les yvelines
tout au long de la crise dans le
département 24 1438 sociétés ont eu
recours au chômage partiel pour près de
300 mille salariés au 1er juin elles
représentent 65% des entreprises du
territoire
concernant les prêts garantis par l'état
7846 sociétés ont bénéficié de cette
mesure pour des crédits atteignant plus
de 1 milliard d'euros
le gouvernement a aussi décidé d'agir
sur les échéances fiscales des
entreprises
au total 43 millions d'euros de recettes
fiscales ont été reportées pour les
établissements situés dans les yvelines
destiné aux tpe pme le fonds de
solidarité abondé par l'état et la
région a permis de soutenir 26 1975
entreprises pour un montant de 66
millions d'euros dans le département